sollte und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video heute geht zwar wieder etwas
von der feinsten sorte wie ein bisschen
schönes nougat aus der welt der online
spiele so die feinsten feinsten
süßigkeiten der slave ich für eine
schalotte es gibt keinen gott verlangt
bis 0 grad aber es gibt was viele von
euch freuen wird und zwar nicht
irgendwie denn wie kommen wir ihnen
heute ein fünf dinge video mit einem
einkauf gameplay video in einer
besonderen version und zwar möchte ich
weil ich wenn ich so zuschauer
kommentare so nach dem motto egal warum
hast jetzt minecraft wieder so viel
geschnitten das soll doch nicht so viel
durchmachen heute erst mal ein
experiment
wir machen das heutige video in
minecraft komplett ungeschnitten
so wie früher in den absoluten oldschool
zeiten das heißt natürlich dass 123456
versprecher mehr drin sein werden als
normalerweise weil ich normalerweise
ausscheidet ich würde sagen wir machen
jetzt einfach mal den klassischen
schilder rein und dann erzähle ich euch
was heute machen denn wir kombinieren
heute ein gameplay video mit einem fünf
arten video und zwar zeige ich euch
heute so ganz nebenbei während ich jetzt
meine fünf wichtigsten dinge in meinem
leben meine fünf wichtigsten dinge denn
ich dachte mir so was könnte man machen
so diese fünf warten wie es findet
eigentlich voll cool weil man irgendwie
schon bevor man auf das video klickt
weiß worum es geht
versteht ihr was ich meine also man
kennt dieses konzept irgendwoher man
weiß okay fünf arten dass jetzt nichts
komplett neues ist nicht so wie sk jagd
sich einfach jeder sack jetzt nicht laut
das wieder gedacht habe dass man dich
aber auf jeden fall kennt ihr dieses 55
arten format auf jeden fall schon
deswegen denke ich mir auch mal soja ist
eigentlich ein stop also man kennt das
irgendwie ist es ihm vertraut und mit
einem klick drauf und weiß hat wirklich
schon mehr oder weniger dass irgendwas
ist mit dem was anfangen kann deswegen
heute die fünf wichtigsten dinge in
meinem leben und bevor wir loslegen mit
dem vorstellen der dinge möchte ich euch
sagen dass ich auf jeden fall mich auf
die dinge hier beschränken
also ich habe bewusst gesagt die dinge
denn
weil sich der eindruck entstehen dass
irgendwie die fünf wichtigsten sachen
überhaupt in meinem leben dinge sind
natürlich nicht an allererster stelle
steht natürlich so etwas wie freunde
familie glück gesundheit
ich will dich dabei versteht was ich
meine ich würde euch nicht einen
eindruck geben dass für mich die
wichtigsten dinge materiell sind also
nach dem motto girls golf auf der welt
nein das ist nicht der fall
deswegen heute dieses video mit diesem
kleinen präfix also es geht wirklich
ausschließlich um dinge wenn man alle
anderen sachen die keine dinge sind
vergisst dann kommen diese fünf dinge
zutage
und darum geht's ich möchte dinge
vorstellen einfach nennen ist was er zu
erzählen worum es mir geht und warum die
dinge für mich wichtig sind okay let's
go an allererster stelle
was nicht heiße dass wichtigste dinges
aber einfach dass es mir als erstes
eingefallen steht mein auto okay jetzt
fragt man sich natürlich warum auto hat
mich mein lambracht er hat mich mal ein
touareg ein rs touareg ich habe einfach
so eine schöne alte kiste mehr oder
weniger
dann fragt man sich natürlich okay warum
will der du jetzt sagen dass sein auto
so wichtig ist wenn es kein porsche m6
ist es liegt einfach daran dass ein auto
für mich für bisschen mehr steht als
einfach nur damit angeben
wobei ich mit meinem war nicht wirklich
angeben kann selbst wirklich will
es verteilt und ja es ist ein cabrio ein
paar von euch haben es auch gleich schon
mal gesehen in irgendwelchen uralten
videos gibt's was zu sehen von mir auf
jeden fall ist die sache die das dich
gern auf marco krauth herbst
verständlich das auto steht für mich
einfach für mobilität
das auto steht für mich für die
möglichkeit dass ich sagen kann ok weißt
du was hier in meinem studio ist mir
langweilig ich fühle mich hier gerade
irgendwie nicht wohl
und dann kann ich sagen okay es ist zwar
jetzt elf uhr nachts
und das ist keine seltenheit es ist
jetzt zwar wo nachts aber ich kann
trotzdem sagen okay ich fühle mich jetzt
hier nicht wohl und ich habe die
möglichkeit einfach sagen zu können ich
habe mein eigenes fortbewegungsmittel
und kann jetzt jeder zeit überall
hinfahren ich kann theoretisch sagen es
wäre es nicht besonders schlau weil
jetzt nicht so den übelsten langstrecken
kruse habt sagen dass ich das zum ersten
kassel oder fahren möchte
und wenn ich will kann ich jetzt nach
barcelona fahren alles was sie dafür
machen muss ist eigentlich nur mal ein
auto volltanken und dann zwischendurch
noch zehn wagen aber ihr wisst ihr was
ich meine
dafür steht für mich ein auto einfach
dafür dass man hier runter fällt in
jumping dafür dass man quasi jederzeit
da hingehen kann wo man will das ist
einfach für mich ein großes stück
persönlicher freiheit
diese diese mobilität und das hat mich
schon immer sehr beschäftigt also früher
als kleines kind habe ich auch immer so
drauf gewartet dass ich endlich 15
bindet mit mofa holen kann und so am
ende hab ich mit seinem ufer geholt aber
ein roller und so dinger waren für mich
immer schon wichtig also irgendwie so
dieses ausbrechen versteht dass man
einfach sagt okay wenn ich jetzt zum
beispiel keinen bock hat irgendwo zu
sein dann kann ich einfach mein auto
nehmen kann irgendwo hingefahren das ist
für mich so ein großes ding und deswegen
wird als erstes eingefallen
ok weiter im text wissen sparte hartmann
ball way weiter im text geht weiter mit
büchern ok wofür stehen bücher also erst
mal lese ich sehr gerne aber bücher
stehen jetzt gar nicht mehr selbst nur
für bücher sondern bücher stehen
sinnbildlich dafür dass man sich im
leben einfach fortbildet was meine also
dass man im leben quasi was lernen
möchte was dazulernen möchte und nicht
nur auf der stelle treten möchte
deswegen habe ich bücher bücher für mich
so wie ich weiß nicht ob viele von euch
lesen ich habe das gefühl lesen war bei
mir damals als ich so in eurem alter war
also so vor fünf sechs jahren schon so
ein ding was nicht so viele gemacht
haben aber gm und der andere ist auch
schon da hab ich das gefühl heutzutage
ist lesen irgendwie noch weiter zurück
rückt in der liste der dinge die die
leute gerne machen oder oft machen
aber lesen ist für mich einfach so ja
ich kann es schwer in worte fassen lesen
ist für mich einfach so ein sinnbild
dafür dass man mit seinem kopf sich
weiterbildet dass man sich intellektuell
stimuliert menschen diese wörter
verwenden möchte und dass man einfach
persönlich auf der stelle tritt sondern
auch dem wunsch hat irgendwas neues
kennenzulernen so diese neugierde und
diese wissbegierig kite weil das ist auf
jeden fall ding was mich persönlich
ausmacht und deswegen bücher mir sehr
wichtig sind
bücher abgehakt dritte sache wenig
überraschend scheiß internet kinder
opfer ein handy kamera wettstein der
comdirect nokia kontakten ist und dass
es sich bei mir so kann man bildstein
warum brauche ich mein handy oder warum
ist mein handy mir wichtig einfach
weiter mit seinem handy heutzutage so
viel machen kann
mit diesen smart smart phones kurzem
eine eigene oma gespielt smartphones
kann man einfach alles mögliche machen
also ich kann mit dem gleichen dingen
mit den gleichen 120 250 40 gramm
material kann ich die gleichen sache
machen also ich kann theoretisch
geschäftliche mails beantworten ich kann
bilder von mir selbst aufnehmen der
mittlerweile so einer geilen qualität
ich kann 4k videos aufnehmen
das müsst ihr euch erst mal vorstellen
das ist eine fotokamera videokamera
e-mail-service dann theoretisch auch
noch in sms service über whatsapp oder
sowas
und es ist natürlich auch immer noch ein
telefon man kann damit telefonieren
alles irgendwie in einem
das ist eigentlich schon schon
fasziniert also wenn man es darauf
anlegt haben mit seinem nun mit seinem
handy hat so viel machen
das ist echt unfassbar und deswegen
einfach weil ich auch mark unterwegs
immer so kleine dinge zu machen mich
immer wieder bisschen produktiv zu
fühlen deswegen ist mein handy auf jeden
fall auch eins meiner wichtigsten fünf
dinge würde ich sagen
weiter ich hab die liste mehr so relativ
spontan ausgedacht weil ich mir dachte
dass dafür etwas gutes warum kommt wenn
man einfach so sagt was einem als erstes
eingefallen ist
aber okay das ist echter teil south
stream verkauft mein gott als ob er
jetzt abstaubt du sack hatte nein du
machst dich ab und du machst jetzt ein
abgang
nein wir können den hohen mann der hat
der hat doch nicht mehr viel habt ihr
gesehen was der gefressen hat auf jeden
fall nicht gesund ich habe übrigens auch
kein food ihr körper mehr anpacken
hey du jane carrey wenn ich dann doch
nicht
habt ihr das gesehen der wald von
unsichtbarer block und der fall wird
drinstecken dankeschön dafür ja ok handy
soviel dazu die nächste wichtigste sache
für mich ist mein pc selbstverständlich
ich bin youtuber und da ist der pc
natürlich somit einer der wichtigsten
sachen weil man als youtuber eigentlich
schon so für und mit youtube lebt man
investiert er soviel zeit rein dass man
ja eigentlich irgendwann ohne youtube
und ohne dieses feedback von den leuten
fast gar nicht mehr leben kann das ist
nicht unbedingt gut also das ist
wirklich so wie eine sucht auf dauer
würde ich sagen das ist echt schon es
ist wirklich nicht ungefährlich und dazu
gibt sich die möglichkeit dass man als
youtube ab einer gewissen größe auch
geld verdienen kann und zwar mehr als
mit einem normalen nebenjob verdienen
könnte und es trotzdem so nebenbei geht
und das ist alles schon sehr sehr
gefährliche combo also das darf man auf
keinen fall unterschätzen
zu guter letzt noch dass hier das echten
springreiter bringt steht für mich für
sport generell hat mir meine liste
sportausrüstung aufgeschrieben bei sport
mittlerweile in meinem leben in sehr
sehr wichtiger bestandteil ist und ich
einfach mittlerweile total mag nicht
beim sport selbst zu pushen und mich
irgendwie selbst zu steigern sei es beim
laufen selbst beim krafttraining sei es
beim urteil
ich habe irgendwie so die begeisterung
für den sport gefunden hätten in den
letzten
paar monaten momentan kann ich selbst
und ich muskelkater in den beinen ab zum
beispiel ist es nicht so wie früher dass
ich mir sagen gott sei dank habe ich
erst am muskelkater und kennst die
nächsten drei tage nicht trainieren
sondern heute denke ich wirklich mag am
liebsten würde ich heute schon wieder
trainieren kann sich über alles super
dreht deswegen sport ist sehr sehr
wichtiger bestandteil meines lebens und
ja das waren so die fünf wichtigsten
dinge in meinem leben wenn ich irgendwas
vergessen habe in euren augen kennt ist
unrein schreiben natürlich auch eure
fünf wichtigsten dinge und reinschreiben
auch sehr gerne reinschreiben was ihr
von seinem bank hat video haltet ihr es
gut oder nein oder nicht besuchen in den
kommentaren und dann bis zum nächsten
mal allein macht's gut und